hi guys it's naughty here hey guys I'm
Archer I'm Sammy bacon and you are
watching glamour tries where we test out
or the latest Beauty trance and products
today I'm going to be using soukous
eyebrow products and I'm going to start
with the frame eyebrow liquid pen and
I'm also going to use their volume
eyebrow mascara which I'll be showing
you a little bit later I've got a busy
day today so I'm going to be heading
into the office and then later on I have
an interview with a makeup artist and
then I'm going to try and sneak in a gym
session after work
so these brow products are meant to be
sweat resistant and long-lasting so I'm
going to apply them in the morning and
really put them to the test
so my makeups pretty much all done or
they like to leave my brows to last
because they really frame the face and
finish the application so I'm gonna take
the framing eyebrow liquid pen first and
just fill in any areas of sparsity they
do actually have full shades of this
kaki Brown camel and grey and I'm sure
there is a shade to fit you in that
range because I want to keep a really
nice natural brow today I will just take
it in short like wispy motions and you
just kind of want to see anywhere areas
that you've got gaps as you can see I've
got a gap here so I'll just go in with
the brow product there rather than a
waxy like texture that pencils have
these are definitely more like an
eyeliner kind of liquid and they start
off wet but once they're on they will
not budge and then I'm going to swap to
the brown pen to do the arch and the
tail of the brow now I finish with the
pan I'm just going to brush my brows up
using the brow mascara just to make sure
that the hair stay in place throughout
the day it's got olive oil and sunflower
oil which are traditional Japanese oils
and it just helps to nourish and treat
to the hairs so as you can see with the
brow that I haven't done yet there's
definitely more definition towards the
front the pen has given me such natural
looking strokes and then you can also
see towards the tail it's nice and full
and the gel is just holding them in
place and literally that took me no time
whatsoever
super super quick super easy and so
excited to see what this product turns
out like in a few hours so it's just dr.
lunch and I'm about to go and interview
of makeup artists so I wanted to make
sure that my makeup is looking flawless
because these people know what they're
talking about so I just had to touch up
my base a little bit but surprisingly
the brows have held up so well I'm so
impressed with this secret product like
it literally still looks exactly the
same as when I applied it this morning
so I'm super happy so I'm just out and
about running my errands I just wanted
to quickly check in with you and let you
know how I'm getting on so far brows are
still looking very much on point they
look great still nice and natural and
I'm gonna check back in with you in the
afternoon so it's early afternoon and I
just wanted to check in and see how my
makeup is holding up my browser really
natural which is exactly what I always
go for I'm a big fan of the no makeup
makeup look and the framing eyebrow
liquid pen from Sookie because there's
really fine hairlike strokes on the
eyebrow so it is late afternoon now and
I'm done running my errands I've glammed
myself up a little bit more as you can
see I've got a lot more makeup on since
this morning I'm actually gonna be doing
some shoots for my socials
which is why I've intensified my look
however I still have my brows on from
this morning so it's still very very
light and natural so I've just finished
in the office for the day and I'm just
in a cab on the way to an event normally
at this time of day my brows are kind of
drop there's a few stray hairs in the
arch but they're completely
Sat so I don't need to reapply and I did
to go
[Music]
okay guys so just finish my workout it
was boxing so trust me it was sweaty and
my brows are still in place they have
held up so well and I have an oily
t-zone as well and these have not been
retouched again since this morning
so if you're after a brow product that
lasts this is a good one I also love
that it still looks natural it hasn't
gone cakey it hasn't gone lucky in the
front of the brow at all so if you're
after natural and long-lasting this is
the product for you so I've just
finished dinner
come out to have a little check on my
makeup and I'm just so impressed my
brows are completely perfect they've
stayed in place all day and I've had a
long day I'd really recommend these
products for anyone who likes a very
luxurious application and for 22 pounds
each I'd say it's definitely worth it
I'm back to my room now after a lovely
evening with some friends and I have to
say my brows are still very much on I
loved that I could build it up
throughout the day so I was able to
start off really nice and light and then
later on just go in with more product
and it didn't look too overpowering
because it believes that watermark
effect so it's not too intense I really
hoped you enjoyed this video I hope
you've learnt a little bit more about
the superfun arts and if you liked it
please give this video a big thumbs up
comment down below and don't forget to
subscribe to glamour UK bye
[Music]